a new CBS News poll out this morning
finds 53 percent of Americans disapprove
of the Republican tax plan a majority of
Americans say the bill will benefit
large corporations and wealthy Americans
but only 31 percent think it will help
middle-class Americans and less than 1/4
believe it will help them and their
families independent senator Bernie
Sanders of Vermont is the ranking member
of the Senate Budget Committee and he
joins us from Washington good morning
senator good morning before we get to
the tax plan I first want to ask you
about your colleague senator Franken I
know you called for him to resign
yesterday but last month you said it was
up to Minnesota what made you change
your mind well I think the additional
evidence that came forward but I think
what we have got to recognize as a
nation that this is a problem not only
impacting high profile men what I worry
about right now as we speak is that in
restaurants and in offices all over this
country where you have bosses who are
not famous there is harassment of women
women are being intimidated and we need
a cultural revolution in this country
and to my mind it has to do with a
woman's right to control her own body to
get equal pay for equal work to have
access to reap her reproductive rights
so we had a lot of work to do to protect
women's equality in this country we
certainly do in senator Franken seselis
and that last allegation was absolutely
not true he has admitted to some but he
said the last one was not true but I've
talked to both Democrats and Republicans
who say this senator Franklin may likely
step down today senator Moore possibly
may be joining the Senate and he has
been accused of far worse than what
senator Franken is accused of what is
your take on that let me take it a
little step further we have a President
of the United States who acknowledged on
a tape widely seen all over this country
that he assaulted women so I would hope
that maybe the President of the United
States might pay attention to what's
going on and also think about resigning
but if your point is that it's not just
Alf Rankin you're absolutely right but I
do want to talk about the absurd tax
proposal that the Republicans pass
on Friday night and I think what your
poll tells us is the American people got
it right and what the American people
understand is that this legislation is a
gift to the largest corporations in this
country who are already doing
phenomenally well in to the wealthiest
people 62% of the benefits in the
Republican Senate tax proposal goes to
the top one percent and large
corporations and at the end of ten years
we're gonna have some 80 million
Americans middle-class Americans paying
more in taxes so in the midst of massive
income and wealth inequality we give tax
breaks to billionaires raise taxes on
the middle class but you're evil but
you're going about that where your point
about it going to is because the
corporate tax rate because what the
Republicans are proposing is that it
would go from thirty five percent to
twenty percent to be fair President
Obama also proposed a reduction in the
corporate tax rate but to about twenty
eight percent are you saying that those
businesses won't reinvest that money in
American businesses and American workers
yes of course that's what I'm saying and
I think that's what they are saying if
anybody thinks that this is going to
result in higher wages and more jobs in
America I don't believe that that's the
case this is trickle-down economic
theory it is a theory that did not work
on the Reagan did not work on the George
W Bush certainly did not work in Kansas
but here's the other point this
legislation drove up the deficit by one
point four trillion dollars and now what
Paul Ryan and other Republican leaders
are saying oh my goodness the deficit
has gone up we have to deal with that
crisis and you know how they're gonna do
it read the front page of the New York
Times the other day they are going to
now come back and cut Social Security
Medicare Medicaid and education so what
this whole thing is about tax breaks for
billionaires and cuts to programs for
the most vulnerable people in this
country and let me also add some people
may remember that during the campaign
candidate Donald Trump he said I'm not
going to cut Social Security Medicare
and Medicaid remember those statements
said it over and over again
well I challenge President Trump today
to tell the Republican leadership that
he will veto any legislation that comes
forward
contradicts the promises that he made to
the American people in terms of Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid
senator another issue at hand is keeping
the government open and keeping it
funded it looks like there will be a
stop-gap plan in place for the next two
weeks but Congress is nowhere near a
permanent deal you have said that you
will not vote for a spending bill
without a permanent fix for dreamers the
president said that if there is a
government shutdown it's gonna be the
Democrats fault are you willing to take
that responsibility no it's certainly
not going to be the Democrats fault let
us all remember last I heard Republicans
control the US Senate Republicans
control the US House and right now what
is going on is Republicans want huge
increases for military spending but they
don't want to provide another nickel to
make sure that we can lower student
loans in this country that we could deal
with the crisis of pensions in this
country right now 10,000 people died
last year because they couldn't get
their claims processed by the Social
Security Administration where funds have
gone down we have enormous issues that
we have got to deal with and instead of
giving tax breaks to billionaires maybe
a time the Republican Party started
looking at the needs of the working
class and middle class of this country
but in 2013 in the shutdown then you
said it is wrong for right-wing
Republicans to ignore the results of the
last election and hold the American
people hostage by threatening to shut
down the government because they can't
get their way what makes this different
some people walking you assuming that we
are shutting down the government we want
to keep who wants to shut down the
government I don't want to shut down the
government I don't know if anybody will
make you a kondal said that this isn't a
pressing issue you still have three
months ago Mitch McConnell said that all
I forgot last I heard Mitch McConnell
was the leader of the Republican Party
who just passed tax breaks that give
they just passed tax breaks for
billionaires and tried to throw 32
million Americans or for the health
insurance they have there will be
negotiations and I hope very much these
negotiations were resolved but we cannot
in the midst of giving tax breaks to
people who don't need it in the midst of
trying to throw millions of people off
the health insurance forget about the
needs of the working class in this
country and the middle class which is
shrinking you know what politics is
about
it's not just doing what you wealthy
campaign contributors want you to do
it's paying attention to ordinary people
all right senator Sanders we're gonna
have to leave it there we thank you very
much for joining us should be a very
interesting day on Capitol Hill today
thanks a lot thank you